Dave siren is the sports editor of the
nation host of the edge of sports he's
got a podcast hashtag or no at edge of
sports and also he's the author of the
book Brazil's dance with the devil the
world cup the Olympics and the fight for
democracy well that sounds like a cheery
story spring in debut joins us now hi
Dave hi it's not the feel-good read of
the season but I still have some fun
stories of like trying to find the
Michael Jackson statue in a favela and
all kinds of other little firsthand
Explorer accounts of what real looks
like today oh great are you going to Rio
yep I will be there on August to the
eighth well good then know what to cross
pens over there I hope so i mean i i'm i
can't say i'm not a little bit nervous
about what's happening there my
expectations are very tremulous i'll
just say that your reaction to michael
jordan's statements yesterday in his
donations were what i think it's so
important that we identify the
difference between politics and
philanthropy because those are two
different things because obviously it's
amazing someone writes a
two-million-dollar check because they
want the world to be a better place and
they want to put their money where their
mouth is good for them but when I hear
people say things like Michael Jordan is
breaking his political silence as if
this is michael jordan's version of
tommy smith and john carlos raising
their fists in 68 or Muhammad Ali
standing up against the war in Vietnam I
mean this is just a different category
of action it's sort of like like getting
a wonderful plate of fish and being like
this is the best steak I ever had I mean
it's fine but it but we should not
confuse it with a political action but
it's a start though at least we're
talking I don't know are we are we
expecting more though because we haven't
heard anything from jordan from for 30
years is that why maybe we're giving him
more credit than he deserves oh yeah oh
no absolutely i mean this was like when
karen's malik started to make movies
again and nobody took a second to ask
whether
the thin red line was actually any good
or not they were just so happy he was
back behind the camera I mean and I
think that that's similar to that that
we were grading this on a big curve
because think about what Jordan is doing
like he's not I mean to me politics
whether you agree with pout the politics
or disagree with the politics inherent
in that question is whether or not the
person is actually taking aside and
fighting for something and what Jordan
is doing explicitly is he's trying to
build a bridge build a bridge between
two communities and have a more peaceful
status quo between police and the
african-american community and they're
all sorts of organizations if you'd
wanted to be political that he could
have given his money to that are taking
a side on this from from black lives
matter two hands up United byp these
organizations are springing up all over
the country of people who are fighting
actively for police reform not police
understanding but police reform so we're
talking about just two very different
things and yeah I absolutely think that
we're grading this on a curve because
when it comes to Michael Jordan are only
expectation at this point in this man's
public life it really is silent what
impact do you think muhammad ali's death
had on any of these athletes that's a
great question and i actually think it
had something profound and this is
really interesting to me because when I
Lee passed away my first instinct that
somebody who's been writing about ollie
known many members of his of his inner
circle and all of this like deep
connection I feel towards Ollie and his
legacy like my first reaction was like
why I wonder if this will just lead to a
sense of relief because he has been so
incapacitated for 20 years and whatnot
but maybe this is just a gentle way to
say goodbye at because he's really been
gone for so long but then when I went to
Louisville for the funeral and I stood
among the hundreds thousands of people
who were throwing flowers at his car as
it went down Main Street in Louisville
and as I spoke to so many ordinary folks
in Louisville who met him and then spoke
to other folks who knew Ali so well who
were there for the services that day I
realized that I was completely wrong and
the mere fact of Ali leaving this earth
seemed to shift people in a way to be
like okay you know week and it was
almost like the opposite of what I
thought it would be like almost like Ali
being in this sort of suspended
animation of Parkinson's disease almost
had people say like well there's alley
he's still with us but then the absence
of Muhammad Ali from this planet the
idea that Muhammad Ali no longer walks
among us the idea of that chain that
link being broken um I really do think
it shifted people to say well someone
better pick up this torch or else it's
just gonna die and I felt that in
Louisville and I think that really did
have had an effect on our general
atmosphere so you I would be remiss to
not think it had some effect on Michael
Jordan and then you had LeBron and
Carmelo you had Dwyane Wade and Chris
Paul any iced grande explicitly
mentioned yet nuit LeBron explicitly
mention Muhammad Ali where any and
explicitly speak about that idea of
picking up the torch in you know the
torch of course has that's that bigger
meaning of Muhammad Ali too because of
the courage of and i gotta tell you Dan
I'm sure you talked about this on your
show when Ali past but I feel like this
has gotten undersold because when I
speak to disability rights activists the
courage of Muhammad Ali in 1996 to be
public with his Parkinson's when he held
that torch I think in this era of social
media were so many people blessedly
blessedly our public about whatever
their their disabilities or challenges
might be we become a little bit callous
to the idea that people were not really
public about those things as recently as
1996 and I've spoken to so many people
it's invalid ID who work on disability
rights issues who just said the sight of
him shaking and holding that torch was a
life changing moment for them of saying
I don't have to be ashamed and I really
do feel like this idea of passing the
torch with Ollie it has that kind of
power where people don't only think of
the 1960s but they think of the 1990s
which of course is much more recent so
Ali when he finally leaves his mortal
coil and goes to the other side people
see that and say my goodness we have
some work to do to make sure this legacy
doesn't die staves ayran the sports
editor of the nation joining a Stan
Patrick show I also wonder about Michael
Jordan maybe Tiger whoa
some of these other athletes who look at
Ali and the legacy that he left was was
not necessarily about boxing it was
about Ali the person so you can have all
the accolades in yet you can have all
the money but what do you really have
when you leave or when you know when
people remember you and I don't know if
that impacts Jordan or tiger or Carmelo
or LeBron but it feels like there's well
a little bit of a shift not a seismic
one but at least a little bit of a shift
here well I've heard some things about
that that's a great question the first
thing is that I think this is affected
LeBron the day he came into the league
like I found this interview with LeBron
from either his first or second year in
the NBA where he said he had two goals
as an NBA player one was to be the
wealthiest athlete to ever live and the
other was as he put it in these are
LeBrons words a global icon like
Muhammad Ali so from the very beginning
LeBron had this idea that this has to be
more about about be about more than
sneaker sales has to be about more than
championships one may be a venue to the
other two that kind of icon status but
you also kinda have to stand for
something the second thing is and I have
no idea this affected Jordan at all but
I've been thinking a lot since I was
passing about uh year old boss so your
old boss is over at ESPN your old
company there and when they did the
athletes of the century in two thousand
and remember a time you know Jordan you
know the memory of the shot over Brian
Russell was still in everybody's mind
and everybody was still like in the
thrall of the Jordan missed and how
Jordan was number one and Ali was number
two of athletes of the century and some
of us squawked about that but at the
same time Michael Jordan was so
unavailable what else could you do I
think if that same boat was taken today
there's just no question that Ali would
be number one because Jordans legend has
faded but Ali's legend has only gotten
bigger when the years and it's hard to
imagine somebody like Michael Jordan
would not pay attention to that fact
about how their relative legends are
being burnished with time yeah we could
have a good discussion I think the
number one athlete on that list should
have been Jackie Robinson not even close
with uh yeah you know correct me if I'm
wrong but I think your old buddy Keith
argued the same thing and I think it's a
very very correct argue I think that's a
very defensible argument I don't know
yeah if you look at just athletically
basketball football track baseball UCLA
the impact that he had you know that
pretty it took a little while for me to
understand all of it because I was the
host of that I I remember doing that and
you're trying to go okay wait a minute
where's Secretariat in their weight
Secretariat in this weight okay George I
it was so important to people Tim Duncan
after the NBA Finals when they won as
we're getting ready to go on
SportsCenter the Spurs had just won the
title in the garden he goes all right so
who's number one on the list he that was
the first thing he asked me when he came
into our little interview room it at
ESPN when we were at the garden so I'm
like it I mean it resonated with people
and it might still resonate with Michael
Jordan I think you bring up a great
point let me ask you to poll question
before I let you go back there because I
got that that that that sports century
that might have been the first story to
go viral before social media yeah yeah
everybody had a top everybody had an
opinion and I remember get me know that
before there was Twitter yeah I remember
guys who were like it how can you put a
horse in there I go I didn't put the
horse in there I just read the script
here I'm a talking hairdo all right
leave me alone mclovin give Dave the
poll question here in the final minute
should the NFL continue to test for
marijuana I know absurd um people have
the right to mitigate their own pain
it's already legal in several states and
when players go to illegal root for
marijuana you're much more likely to get
a dangerous strain much rather have it
be legal aboveboard and mild for players
who are mitigating but just the life of
living in the NFL the only problem I
have dave is how can the Commissioner
say that and not I mean how do you
present it where you're you're not
signing off on marijuana use as much as
you just want to ease the testing on
marijuana use sort of behind the scenes
yeah I mean I heard something else make
this point so I don't want to pass this
away as an original idea but I can't
remember who said it but they could also
do something and maybe it's not the most
courageous move in the world but they
could do something where they they say
it's against the rules
but they stop testing for it not unlike
what they did with so many years for
steroids we're not allowed to take
steroids but they didn't test for that
might be a way that might be too cute by
half in the 21st century but it also
might be a way to handle that problem
Dave always great to talk to you thank
you my privilege everybody that's a Dave
siren the sports editor of the nation
host of the edge of sports also the
author of the cheery book Brazil's dance
with the devil the world cup the
Olympics and the fight for democracy the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience